party urlaub wären corona das sollte
eigentlich nicht gehen auf mallorca
beispielsweise wird jetzt auch rigoros
dagegen vorgegangen
in bulgarien am goldstrand sieht das
ganz anders aus deswegen haben wir
einmal bei den urlaubern nachgefragt ob
sie denn gar keine angst vor der
pandemie haben also das ding ist
natürlich mein fach wie immer niemand
achtet darauf niemand achtet man abstand
einhält
es ist immer noch die stimmung wie
gesagt ist genau gleich geblieben also
es ist wie immer ohne einschränkung
das sind wir ziemlich von innen und
wegen alkohol und deswegen ist alles gut
also mir ist es eigentlich egal mit dem
abstand ich halte mich so wie normal
also ich finde jetzt nicht so jemand der
dann
man muss den abstand abhalten anhalten
und
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ein merino
vorpommern gibt es keine kohle
also ich bin für mich ist diese
krankheit nicht da ganz einfach sagen
ich bin seit januar in berlin auf
baustellen wenn es mit 1000 leuten
zusammen gewinnt ich kenne keinen der
kommune hatte ich halte es für eine lüge
von der abwechslung auch jetzt in
deutschland weil daher meine da kann man
ja auch nichts machen weist das auf
jeden fall schön mal hier was machen zu
können
und am goldstrand ist für uns kein
kirchweg 1 kurz vor halb sieben startet
die party jetzt am goldstrand schon
wieder hallo nele ja so langsam staaten
die partys ab 20 21 uhr geht's langsam
los dann kommen die leute aus ihren
hotels die sind dann fertig mit mit
ihrem abendessen und dann geht so
langsam los es sind ja doch unglaubliche
bilder die uns dort erreichen von
abstand nichts zu sehen von
mundschutzmasken auch nichts machen die
behörden wirklich nichts in bulgarien
also einzige was ich hier zweimal
gesehen habe das fieber gemessen worden
ist in zwei klubs aber auch nur so die
ersten zwei stunden dann habe ich noch
zwei polizeiautos gesehen hier am strand
das war eigentlich alles also es gibt
ganz wenige menschen die eine maske aus
haben eigentlich so gut wie gar keinen
es ist schon ein bisschen beunruhigend
auch für mich weil ich so was natürlich
auch jetzt die letzten wochen monate
nicht kenne